hey youtubers is Charlie this is gonna
be my flash episode 7 video so so many
comic book things that we have to talk
about so let's just get to it careful
for spoilers if you haven't seen the
episode yet there is a new round of the
reverse flash ring giveaway - all you
have to do to enter that is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video
lots of people put in rings on things so
let's just start with top 5 WTF number 5
Henry Allen is back this is a huge deal
he's the person that helps Barry get his
mojo back
like his body is fine as Caitlin
explains it and if you forgot his dad is
a medical doctor so he looks at his
x-rays - it tells Barry the same thing
well it looks like your spine is fine
but Barry has lost his confidence so he
gets this really long really intense
speech from his dad about how his dad
went through the same kind of thing
where he got destroyed when he was on
trial for supposedly killing his wife he
was able to survive it move forward
Barry eventually does the same thing
just to tab over - Henry Allen zoom
theories he did say that while he's been
away he's been fishing like zoom said he
was fishing but aside from that in the
intensity and swagger of the character
this week I'm not sure that there was
more evidence that he is zoom now there
is a hunter Zola monarch in the comics
where hunter zolomon becomes the
character zoom and tries to make his
best friend Wally West a better flash by
challenging him so if you want to take
Henry Allen to zoom you could take like
a modified hunter solo monarch from the
comics and just give it to his dad like
a dark earth - version of his dad but
just to be clear I think that this is
earth one Henry Allen and he is just
Barry's dad he's not anybody in disguise
it is pretty cool to know that his dad's
been enjoying himself from the great
outdoors since he's been locked up for
so long but on the number for The Ballad
of Cisco and Hawkgirl so he starts
vibing on her starts learning about
mysterious Birdman no wait maybe they're
angels
Birdman would be silly that'd just be
ridiculous I know they aired the promo
for the flare episode at the end of this
and you see a lot of Hawkman talking to
Hawkgirl obviously that's when we're
gonna meet him for the first time but I
do like the idea this non-starter
Hawkgirl Cisco relationship he gives her
the Lloyd Dobler at the end from say
anything Princess Bride I heard it's a
good date movie and a lot of people have
been wondering about the wings this is
like the first full shot that I've seen
of the wings but I'm gonna do like a
completely separate video just for that
trailer because
a whole lot of stuff going on in there
taking the hawkman hawkgirl back stories
and tying them together with Vandal
Savage in a way that they did not in the
comics there's a whole bunch of other
stuff besides this episode that we have
to talk about so that's why I'm gonna do
a separate video but on a number three
brought his back and he wants Caitlyn to
help him make more super smart gorillas
even though there was so much stuff
going on in this episode we had the
reverse flash ring we had earth to
gorilla City
this was really danielle Panabaker
episode this is like a Caitlyn episode
because the garage story was the a story
yeah Barry is dead you have patty you
have like all these other storylines
Grodd was the big story and that was
Caitlyn's story flash does supersonic
punch him into the wormhole to earth to
but it's really Caitlyn that talks him
down she's the one that saves the day
it's kind of nice to see her get scenes
like that when so many of them hit the
cutting room floor last year there was
actually a Jay Garrick scene that she
had in jitters from earlier this season
that also got cut like it was in a
trailer but it didn't make it into the
final episode the weird thing about
episodes and are really any TV show in
general is that they shoot way more
scenes than they have room to fit in the
final episode so a lot of good stuff
just hits the cutting room floor because
there's not room for it but danielle
Panabaker totally on point is and arrow
- grodd's King Kong this is totally not
a story about how Grodd is evil this is
a story about how Grodd just wants more
like him like he wants to make a home
for himself which they are happy to give
him but on to my number two WTF Harrison
wells of Earth - cosplays is a Barth on
the reverse-flash wearing an extra
costume as cisco explains it that they
found in the Time Vault just to explain
what's going on here I saw a lot of
confusion on Twitter the Time Vault is
the secret room that AO barred Thawne
had at STAR Labs that still exists
Gideon does not Gideon is not there
anymore but Cisco explains he found a
spare costume inside that time vault the
speech that Cisco had Harrison wells
practicing was the speech that eobard
thawne gave to him last season before he
killed him before he you know he put his
hand through his heart that's why Cisco
was like you got to make it creepier
which I just I just love and the funny
thing is is you have to look at Tom
Cavanagh hair in this episode the
hairstyle for a abarth on is way crazier
than Harrison wells I know here watches
a total Game of Thrones Kit Harington
thing but you could also totally do a
flash version of that
with Harrison wells I think my favorite
fake reverse-flash moment though was as
they were slowly losing ground like as
he was getting ready to turn on them and
Harrison wells just turns the juice up
on his crazy and tells grant I made you
a promise I intend to keep that the city
will be yours and Caitlin and Cisco are
watching off in the distance like they
can't tell if he's lying anymore but if
it wasn't clear none of that would have
been possible without Caitlin defeating
Harrison wells of earth two's objections
like he totally wanted to go home he's
like I'm done with this
Caitlin won him over this is a team
right so that was Caitlin's other big
victory in this episode just proving
that she could be just as important as
the flash just in case you missed it
they were like hey we should destroy
this costume Barry's like yeah but see
if you can fit my costume in this little
ring so that is the teaser for the
official flash ring and yeah they
probably make it look a little bit
different they probably give it the
white emblem on my number one WTF though
they send Gorilla Grodd to earth to
gorilla City
that's where gorilla City is like he
shows up and it looks like Planet of the
Apes obviously he's gonna try and take
over that society that might be where
they tried to bring in solovar or it
could just be the story broads rise to
power I don't know if they're gonna do
Grodd again this season hopefully
they'll do him in the back half and
we'll get a better look at gorilla City
but yeah it is definitely gorilla City
from the comics it's just on earth too
in earth 2 all comic book things are
possible a couple of the big things that
didn't really fit into my top five patty
figuring out what's going on with Barry
she knows that he's lying he did not
come clean and tell her he is the flesh
so she still doesn't know but she'll
probably figure it out eventually I
think what they're doing with that is
just taking the iris figures out Barry
is the flash storyline and making it a
much more deliberate thing like you know
teasing it out turning it into his own
big story and speaking of iris she was
the one that called Henry Allen to come
help Barry
so if you want to give anyone credit for
giving Barry his mojo back you have to
give it to Iris although technically it
was that super intense speech from John
Wesley Shipp and Joe we have to say
something about Joan this episode he
advocated for killing Grodd he I mean he
thought it was justified based on all
the people that Grodd had hurt but he
was also the one who told iris it's not
murder if it's your doppelganger so
there's this weird thing in season two
where Joe is beginning super intense
so everybody let me know
comments what was your favorite moment
from this episode there were so many
like big WTF reveals especially gorilla
City I feel like that was what made
everybody freak out the most what's
gonna happen next is is there is no
flash and arrow next week like there's a
new episode of arrow tomorrow night just
like normal but next week they're on
break then the week after that they come
back and do the big flare OH crossover
so I already have the promo for that I'm
gonna do a separate video that's gonna
explain
hawkman hawkgirl and how that's gonna
tie in with vandal savage's story so
just stay tuned for that that'll be like
the next video that I post while you
guys wait for all that stuff to post you
can click here for my Captain America's
Civil War post credits scene and you can
click here for all my other arrow and
flash videos thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight